With a boosted model, there are not many
results that come out of the model that
can be interpreted in accuracy terms.
To do this,
a validation of the model is needed.
We will get to this part in a bit, but
for now, let's go over the two important
items that we can actually examine
in the boosted models results.
The first thing we would want to look
for is the variables important plots.
Just like we saw in the forest model,
this can help us know which
variable delivers the most
insight to the target variable.
The other item of interest in
the results is the number of
iteration assignment plot.
This helps us show
the amount of variance, or
rather deviance that is
captured with more iterations.
The question this answers is how many
trees are needed to create the optimal
result?
Now that we know a little background
on what we're going to look for,
how about we go look at the results for
a model over in Alteryx?